يعني أنا مثلًا لما جلست مع «ميسي» وزوجته
قالت أنا بجي
الناس بس هاجموها مسكينة
إيه، شكّوا فيها
هي اللي ما تبغى
ترى هي، أنا أعتقد ما أبغى أجزم
أعتقد أنها بتجي هي وصديقاتها للسعودية للسياحة
بدون زوجها، وبدون عقد، وبدون ما ندفع لهم ولا ريال
معقولة؟
معقولتين
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية
وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحوّل وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقة اليوم هو الأستاذ «فهد حميد الدين»
الرئيس التنفيذي وعضو مجلس إدارة الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
حلقة مهمة جدًّا لشرح مفهوم
هوية المدن وتسويق المدن وتسويق الدول
واللي كانت هي البداية اللي سولفنا فيها
ثم دخلنا على ملف السياحة في السعودية
ليش هذا الرهان الكبير من السعودية على ملف السياحة؟
والدخول بثقل من خلال الوزارة، الهيئة
المشاريع الكبرى السياحية والاستثمارات الضخمة في هذا القطاع؟
ليش هيئة ووزارة وصندوق؟
شرحنا أدوار كل كيان من هذه الكيانات
دخلنا في موضوع
هل استعجلنا في فتح السعودية؟
وهي لم تكتمل بُناها التحتية ومرافقها السياحية؟
كيف رضى المجموعات الأولى من السياح
اللي جاؤوا وخاضوا هذه التجربة؟
هل كانوا راضين ويوصون بهذه التجربة للآخرين؟
تكلمنا على موضوع سفراء السياحة
من لعيبة الكرة المشاهير مثل «ميسي» و«كريستيانو»
كيف سفيرنا في السياحة ما يبغى يعيش عندنا؟
اللي هو «ميسي»
تكلمنا على موضوع ارتفاع الأسعار
استهداف أغلب المشاريع للطبقة الأغنى في السعودية
وربما عدم وجود خيارات للشريحة المتوسطة
وناقشنا بطبيعة الحال كل التفاصيل الصغيرة
حقت هل نقدر نافس الدول المجاورة اللي تقدم خيارات أرخص؟
وأيش مقومات النجاح اللي عندنا؟
إلى آخر هذه النقاط
أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله أبو سارة، شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يحييك أبو يارا، سعيد أني أكون معكم
الله يسعدك، أخيرًا صارت
أرجع أشيّك الواتساب
أقول للناس من متى قاعد أحاول فيها وللا ما يحتاج؟
هذا السؤال الأول وللا أيش؟
من بدايتها كذا!
الله يسلمك
لا والله، احنا سعداء بأننا نكسبك ضيف
وبنحكي عن ملفات رهيبة
بس قبل ما نحكي عن الملفات هذه
خلينا نسمع منك حكايتك مع التنس
لأنه اللي أنا أعرفه اليوم أنه فيه كذا موجة
أو يسمونها هبّة البادل في 2019، 2020، 2021
ناس أثبتوا وكملوا احتراف في هذا الموضوع
وراعيين الهبّة الآن حولوا تنس
توّهم باديين في التنس وأكاديميات التنس
أنت ما شاء الله، الظاهر من سنين في الموضوع هذا
ووصلت لمرحلة احترافية، فأيش اللي طيّحك في التنس؟
هم قالوا لي أنك أنت بتطلّع معلومات ما أتوقعها
لا طبعًا، عندي مصادري
واضح
يا طويل العمر، أنا ما كان لي في الكرة كثير
وكان وزني كبير، فكنت شكلي دائري أكثر
هذا وأتكلم عن عمري 12 أو 13
لما ألعب كرة، الكل يعلّق
وكنت أتضايق؛ فما عاد ألعب
أنت آخر واحد يختارونه إذا جاؤوا يسوون الفريق؟
أنت آخر واحد يختارونه صح؟
اللي يتورطون فيه
إيه بالضبط
التنس ما أحد يشوفها، ولا أحد يلعب تنس آنذاك
فقلت هذه مساحة بسيطة
إلين ما جاني مدرب برازيلي، كان يكلم آخرين
يقول إيه بس فهد، ما بيجري
أذكر وقتها، قلت أنا لازم أنحف
إذا أبغى ألعب أي رياضة؛ لازم أنحف
وفعلًا، نزلت عن وزني
وقتها كنت تدرس في أي مدرسة؟
معهد العاصمة
أنا طال عمرك، ربيت هنا في الرياض
درست في معهد العاصمة، وبعدين درست في جامعة البترول
ما رحت مدارس حكومية، ولا درست برّا
منتج محلي 100%
ما رحت مدارس خاصة قصدك؟
إيه، ما رحت مدارس خاصة
لا، ولا درست برّا
وترى فيه نظرية على فكرة
يقولون إذا قابلت أحد من البترول
خلال ثلاثين ثانية لازم يعلمك أنه درس في البترول
فما شاء الله عليك أنت صمدت معانا دقيقة ونص
إلين علمتنا أنك خريج البترول
لازم كلكم تقولوا المعلومة هذه؟
ما شاء الله عليهم صراحة
فضوليين؟
إيوه المراقبين هذولي اللي يقولون لك هذا الكلام
أيش اللي مضايقهم في الموضوع؟
فنرجع لموضوع التنس، فأنت أخذتها كتحدي أنك أنت تنحف
صحيح
وساعدتك تنحف؟
27 كيلو طال عمرك
أوه على ذاك العمر نتكلم احنا على يمكن نصف وزن راح
فعلًا لو تشوف صوري وأنا عمري 14 سنة يمكن 13
ما تصدق أنه هذا نفس الشخص
بس بعدين الحمدلله، واحترفت ولعبت لمدة سنين
ودخلت منتخب المملكة في التنس
وكان ترتيبي الثالث ومثّلت المملكة فيه
بس بعدين خلاص اشتغلت ونسيت ورجعت زدت 10 كيلو
لا، لسّه ما شاء الله أمورك طيبة
الحمدلله
بس الفترة هذه معاد ترجع تلعب تنس
خلاص هذيك علاقتك في التنس انتهت
يالله ألعب بادل شوي
آه بادل، هذه حقت الدببة يسمونها اللي ما يحتاج حركة واجد
الله يسلمك شكرًا
أنا أكثر واحد
أنت ما شاء الله نحفان
ألعب اللعبة هذه
صدق أنت نحفان
الله يبشرك بالخير
وحتى من آخر لقاء، ما شاء الله عليك
إذا إلى الأشوى؛ الحمدلله
لا، مبيّن
وبديت ألعب تنس، يعني قاعدين نحاول نبني المهارة هذه
ونمشي مع الهبّة، ونشوف وين بيودونا الناس
كل سنتين رياضة جديدة، نحاول نتعلمها
تمام، خلاص نلعب تنس إن شاء الله
نلعب تنس، بس أنت تقول لي منذ زمان، لا تفاجئني بمستواك
لا ما عليك ألعب
تمام، احنا أبو سارة مبسوطين أننا نكسبك صراحةً اليوم
على موضوع الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
ونبغى نفتح الملف، ونفهم دوركم، ونفهم أيش سويتوا
بس قبل التصوير سولفنا على موضوع هوية المدن
وأسهبت فيه، وأنت رجل ريادي وقيادي في موضوع التسويق بشكل عام
فحبيت المفهوم اللي أنت حكيت عنه في موضوع تسويق المدن
بستأذنك قبل ما ندخل في الهيئة ومواضيعها
أنك تسولف لنا شوي على موضوع
ليش مهم موضوع هوية المدن؟
وكيف هذه الهويات تؤثر في الفرص
وتؤثر في اقتصاد المدن لما يصير عندها هوية واضحة؟
يمكن ابتداءً قبل ما نتكلم عن الهوية
أي مدينة تنمو بنمو اقتصادها
فأيش محركات النمو لأي مدينة؟
عندك استثمارات، عدد سكاني وسوق
منتجات وخدمات اللي هي تنمّي التبادل التجاري داخليًا وخارجيًا
وفيه السياحة، استقطاب الزوار، اللي يأتوا وينفقوا في أي مدينة
فبالتالي أي مدينة عندها هوية
المفروض أن الهوية تؤثر على خمس
خطابات موجهة لشرائح مختلفة
الخطاب الأول، اللي هو استثمر في المدينة
الخطاب الثاني، اللي هو زور المدينة
نحن نقول روح السعودية
الخطاب الثالث، لاستقطاب كفاءات وكوادر للسكن
اسكن في المدينة
وهنا جودة الحياة والفرص التعليمية والتدريبية
والرابع، يمكن التعلم أو النمو
كثير دول ما تروح عشان تعيش فيها
بس تروح تتعلم تدرس وترجع
وأخيرًا، التصدير أو صُنع
إذا تقول في بلد صُنع في مثلًا اليابان، وللا صُنع في فرنسا
مو بمثل صُنع في بعض الدول اللي غير معروفة مثلًا
فكل ما كان عندك هوية تخدم هذه الخطابات
وتعزز قوتك في هذه الخطابات
كل ما ساعدت في التنمية الاقتصادية على كل مجال من هذه المجالات
الآن، بناء الهويات طال عمرك في نظري
وشكرًا على إطرائك قد لا أستحقه
لكن هناك هويات صُنعت لقصد، وهناك هويات صُنعت بدون قصد
مثلًا فيه دراسة قريتها عن نيويورك
نيويورك يقول لك أنها أصبحت عندها هوية
أنها العاصمة المالية في العالم، أو في أمريكا كحد أدنى
يعني العاصمة
المالية للعالم، صحيح
بالضبط
تجي تشوف طيب نيويورك مليانة ناس في الشوارع
مليانة جرائم، مليانة وصخ، بس ما تُعرف، ماهي معروفة بها
طيب كيف تكونت هذه الصورة الذهنية؟
أو هذه الشخصية أو الهوية عن المدينة
تقول الدراسة أنه فيه فئة من سكان المدينة ما تتعدى
هذه الفئة نسبتها من 5-8%
هي اللي تشكّل هوية وشخصية المدينة
مين هذا الـ 5% أو 8% هم ثلاث شرائح
الشريحة الأولى والأهم، هم رواد الأعمال والمحترفين
اثنين، التعليم
شريحة القطاع الأكاديمي
والثالث، القطاع الإعلامي
وإذا هذولا الثلاثة اتحدوا؛ بتشوف تعظيم الأثر في بناء الهوية
خل نطبقها على نيويورك
نطبقها على نيويورك
احنا بنتكلم عن أنها عاصمة مالية
المقرات الرئيسية للبنوك كلها متمركزة في نيويورك
هذا دليل أنه هما محترفين؟
بالضبط، هذا الشريحة الأولى
وهنا العلاقة الوظيفية بين الشركات دي وموظفيها
بتدربهم، فاستحدثت برامج تدريبية
في جامعات كبرى مثل ما صار في نيويورك
هذا قطاع الأكاديمي اللي هم الشريحة الثانية
الشريحة الثالثة؟
«بلومبيرق»
أكبر مؤسسة إعلامية في القطاع المالي هي «بلومبيرق»
مقرها الرئيسي في نيويورك
ولما الثلاثة هذولا يتحدوا؛ يبنوا هذه الصورة الذهنية عن هذا المدينة
احنا على سبيل المثال في الظهران المنطقة الشرقية
ترى تشكلت شخصية المنطقة الشرقية زمان
بناءً على «أرامكو» وجامعة البترول
اللي هو القطاع الأكاديمي، وجريدة «اليوم»
هذولا الثلاثة، المجتمع ترى ما كان يشكّل كم؟
موظفين «أرامكو» 22 ألف وقتها؟
وطلاب ومنسوبي جامعة البترول 4 آلاف آنذاك
وجريدة «اليوم» ما أدري كم عدد الموظفين
بس هذول شكّلوا...
الـ 30 ألف هذولي...
30 ألف صحيح
30 ألف
شكّلوا نمط الحياة وهوية الظهران وإن كانت لم تسوّق
فهذا اللي نتكلم عن الغير مقصود، احنا اليوم المقصود
عندك التخطيط الاستراتيجي لتسويق المدن
آسف، وهنا موضوع مرة ثانية حتى نموذج الظهران
هو نموذج بالمصادفة مثل نيويورك
صحيح غير مقصود، بالضبط
أنه فيه شركة «أرامكو» جات، فجذبت جامعة البترول
لأنها محتاجة مؤسسة أكاديمية تدرّب المهنيين أو المهاريين
أو المحترفين اللي تحتاجهم «أرامكو»
وبعدين جريدة «اليوم» تفاعلت مع هذا الوسط اللي مليان ناس
من توجّه أو قطاع أو مجال معين
و صارت تتشكل معاه؛ فتشكلت هوية الظهران بهذه الطريقة
اللي اليوم يمكن نقدر نقول أن الظهران أكثرها
ترتيب، تنظيم
ترتيب، تنظيم، سواقة
ناس جادين جدًّا، تنامون بدري
بالضبط، متى ينامون
هذه الهوية، وهم نسبتهم الأقل بكثير
من مئات الآلاف اللي في المنطقة الشرقية
الآن كيف احنا نستفيد من هذا المفهوم؟
أولًا بس بوضح أن نيويورك ما عندها شخصية وحدة مثل العاصمة المالية
العاصمة المالية للشرائح المهتمة
ويمكن هي الأشهر أو الصورة الذهنية هي الأشهر
لا، بس هي كمان عاصمة الفنون والمسرح «البرود واي»
لكن تجي تشوف أفضل مسارح في العالم في نيويورك
والمحترفين هناك، اللي يكتبون السيناريوهات
اللي يصممون الملابس وإلى آخره
جامعات معهد الموضة للفنون هناك في نيويورك
كل الإعلام الفني اللي متمركز عندك بين هوليوود وبين نيويورك
ونيويورك يخدم هذا القطاع
الجوائز الإعلامية في المسرح كلها في نيويورك مقرها
فتكونت هذه الهوية
الآن الشطارة بالنسبة لنا أننا نأخذ هذا المفهوم
ونطبقه على الهويات اللي موجودة
أو الهويات اللي لسّه بنصنعها لوجهات جديدة
بس مثلًا نتكلم عن هوية موجودة نبغى نعززها ونبنيها، المدينة المنورة
المدينة؛ هذه مدينة النور ومدينة السكينة
خذ السكينة
السكينة كمفهوم المفروض أننا نعززه في المدينة
لأنه يخدم كل زوار وقاصدي هذه المدينة
كيف تطورها؟ على مستوى التشريع
إذا بتتكلم عن السكينة
من أبسط شيء؛ امنع البواري إلى بناء الكود العمراني
اختيار الألوان، أنه لازم من كل بقعة في المدينة تشوف المآذن
ترى الجوار، هذه المدينة بكل ما لديها من تاريخ
كيف ألّفت بين المهاجرين
والأنصار
بالضبط، مو بس هذا فيها كثير مواقع
الرسول -اللهم صلِّ وسلم عليه- كان يمشي إلى مسجد «قباء» على رجوله دائمًا
هذا المسار اليوم «جادة قباء» طوروها وأنسنوها
ونبغى نحافظ على نفس التجربة اللي ممكن واحد يستحضر فيها
سيرة الرسول اللهم صلِّ وسلم عليه، خاصةً أنك أنت إلى جوار مرقده
جبل «أُحد» أحبه هو...
تأكيد على كلامك أبو سارة
أنا هذا الشعور بالضبط هو اللي جاني لما زرت المدينة عدة مرات
موضوع السكينة، موضوع الراحة
وربطتها بمثلًا اللي يروحون مصحات في سويسرا
وللا يروحون مصحات في أسبانيا حتى يستجمّوا
وللا حتى يعيدوا الاتصال بروحهم
وهذه قطاع وسوق واعد جدًّا
فأرسلت لمعالي «الفياض» رئيس مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
كنت أقول له، معاليك نحن ندفع فلوس عشان نروح لأوربا
واحنا نقعد في نهاية جوّا منتجع، وللا جوّا مصحة
تخيل لو هذا موجود في فرع مستشفى التخصصي اللي في المدينة المنورة
أنت بالفعل روحانيًا تتشافى بوجودك في المدينة المنورة
فما بالك لو أضفت لها الجزء الطبي، والجزء الإكلينيكي
أو الجزء العلاجي اللي ممكن يتوفر في منتجعات
فأنت هنا، إذا تشكلت هوية المدينة المنورة بهذه الطريقة
أنت جذبت حتى المستثمر اللي يجي يبني مصحة
للاستجمام أو للاستشفاء في المدينة المنورة
طلاب الجامعة الإسلامية اللي قاعدين يجون من أنحاء العالم
بس حتى يكونوا جنب الحرم النبوي
احنا عندنا هوية شبه مشكّلة، ودك تبني عليها وتعززها
وتبني عليها اقتصاديًّا في الاستثمارات
مثل ما ذكرت المصحات ومراكز الاستشفاء
أو حتى اقتصاديًّا، أتكلم عن القطاع العقاري
كثير ناس تبغى تتملّك
صحيح
وسيدي سمو ولي العهد أعلن أنه بيكون فيه
السماح للتملك الأجانب حتى في مكة والمدينة
طيب خلني أسألك سؤال شوية...
بس عفوًا، هذا اقتصاديًّا بيمثّل فرصة هائلة
مو بس لمن يزور
ولكن من يكون عنده سكن وبيت ثاني يكون مقصد له ولأقاربه
وهذا بيعزز من عدد الزيارة والإنفاق في المدينة
وهذا اقتصاديًّا، وكلها تبني على الهوية اللي هي السكينة
وهنا بعد نقدر نكمل الأجزاء الخمسة أو الخطابات الخمسة اللي أنت قلت عنها
تمام
صنع في المدينة مثلًا من المدينة المنورة
تمر من المدينة المنورة
إيه
أيش وزنها بالنسبة للعالم الإسلامي؟
لما تقول هذه صادرات تمور من المدينة المنورة
من عجوة المدينة
أنت تتكلم على قصة مختلفة
فيعني هنا عندنا فرص هائلة
وأتمنى أنه فعلًا نبدأ نشوف هويات المدن تتشكّل
أعطيك مثال، عجوة المدينة الآن مصدّرة
لكن أفكر في منتج جديد، صنع في المدينة
ما قد أحد يفكر أحد فيه يمكن
أكيد يمكن فيه سبقوني ناس، بس ما قد طُرح كصناعة
خل نستفيد يمكن نطلع بقرشين بعد الحلقة
بس مثلًا فعلًا جبل «أُحد»، وجبل «الرماة»
جبل «الرماة» اليوم هي قصة غزوة «أُحد»
الآن بالمقارنة مع «روبن هود» هذا اللي عنده القوس والرمح
لما تروح في بريطانيا في شافيلد
يقول لك 52% من مبيعات شافيلد رمح «روبن هود»
بالله لكل هالمسلمين اللي يأتونا بالملايين
مو المفروض يشتروا رماح من المدينة؟
كتذكار لهذا المكان التاريخي
بالضبط، وهذا الرمح ممكن يكون بريالين بلاستيك تجيبه للأطفال
أو يكون جلد وخشب ينباع بـ 10 آلاف
وهذا اقتصاد هذا منتج واحد
بس عندك القصة وعندك الرواية والتاريخ والإرث
اللي يخليه منتج لازم تشتريه وأنت هناك
كل هذه أمثلة لمدن تشكلت هويتها بالصدفة
أبغى مثال لمدينة بالتخطيط
هي شكلت هويتها كما تشاء وليس بالصدفة
أنا أعتقد اللي تقوم به المملكة في العُلا مثال حي على التخطيط المقصود
نتكلم عن  متحف مفتوح، متحف تاريخي مفتوح
تتكلم عن الآن بيطرحوها أن زيارتك للعُلا رحلة عبر الزمن
فعلًا يأخذوك إلى آلاف قبل ...
جيوب «الديفيندر» القديمة
طيارات المراوح هذه التاريخية، القطار اللي قيد الإنشاء
والتلوث البصري، والتلوث السمعي
وكله مقنن للحفاظ على هذه الرحلة عبر الزمن
داخل المنتجعات الظاهر ممنوع حتى الإسفلت
والإسفلت له لون من لون
التربة
التربة، بالضبط
فبالتالي بنحاول نحافظ على هذا المفهوم أنه متحف تاريخي مفتوح
ومرورك في العُلا أو بقائك؛ كأنها تجربة في رحلة عبر الزمن
وهذه كلها
الفنادق ما تشوف علامات تجارية وأسواق، أبدًا
برج زجاجي ما في
حتى الابتكار للمبنى الزجاجي كان مرايا عشان يعكس لك
هذه الآثار اللي تركت لنا إياها الحضارات النبطية أو من مر بهذيك الحضارات
ولما نتكلم عن العُلا كمحافظة صغيرة جدًّا
وبرضه فيه شغل على هويتها
هل هذا يعني أن كل المدن بحاجة إلى هوية؟
هل لازم تكون عندنا هوية لكل مدينة؟
أنا قاعد أقول لك، أي مدينة لا بد أن تبني اقتصادها
بحجم طموحها وحجم إمكانياتها أو ميزها التنافسية
ممكن ما تكون عندها إمكانيات لكن تستثمر فيها
لأن عندها ميز تنافسية ممكن استغلالها
الآن سؤالك، هل لازم يكون لها هوية؟
وأقول لك هل تسوّق وللا ما تسوّق؟
كيف تبني منتج وما تسوّق له؟
أكيد تسوّق له، هو لازم تبني هوية
لأنه بيعطيك التعظيم الأكبر مما بنيته ووفرته للموجودين أو الزوار
خلنا ندخل على ملفنا أبو سارة الآن الأساسي في هذه الحلقة
اللي هو موضوع الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
ويمكن نبدأ أول شيء بأننا نقول
ليش هذا الرهان المضخم من وجهة نظر بعض الناس
من جانب السعودية، فيه رهان مضخم على قطاع السياحة
فإنشاء وزارة، إنشاء هيئة، أربعة أو خمسة مشاريع سياحية عملاقة
فيه تسارع عجيب في هذا الملف، البعض حتى يقول مبالغ فيه
يا أخي فيه قطاعات أهم، روحوا للتصنيع، روحوا للتعدين، أولى وأهم
خلنا نبدأ من ليش هذا الاستثمار المضخم في قطاع السياحة؟
أعتقد ثلاثة أسباب
السبب الأول، أن السياحة كأي قطاع يساهم في بناء الناتج المحلي
وتشوف كل الدول الناجحة سياحيًا؛ القطاع السياحي يساهم
معدل 10% طبعًا في بعض الدول اللي مرتكزة على القطاع السياحي
مثل المالديف وللا سيشيلز
نسبة مساهمة القطاع السياحي في الناتج المحلية يصل إلى 70%
لكن نتكلم عن دول مجموعة العشرين على المتوسط
معدل المساهمة تتعدى 10% بشويه
فاحنا نبغى 10% كحد أدنى
احنا كم؟
بدينا 3% في 2018
فبالتالي عندك تنمية اقتصادية بعيدة عن النفط
والمساهمة بتكون ثلاث ضعاف كحد أدنى لما كنا عليه في 2018
السبب الثاني قد يكون هو الأهم، توفير الوظائف
اليوم كل القطاعات قاعدة تودّع وظايفها للأتمتة
وتخسر وظائف للأتمتة
مجلس السفر والسياحة العالمي يقول
«في العشر سنوات اللي مضت
السياحة ساهمت بوظيفة من كل خمس وظائف جديدة أو مستحدثة
وبعد 2025 السياحة ستساهم بواحد من كل أربع وظائف مستحدثة»
فبالتالي الوظائف الجديدة اللي متوقعة من القطاعات قاعدة تنقص
ومن السياحة بتزيد
الآن، الأهم مو بس العدد، ولكن النوع
ترى البطالة مشكلتها مو بس مع الوظائف
الناس اللي عندهم شهادات جامعية وعندهم خبرات تخصصية
كل ما نزلت في مستوى التأهيل، كل ما وجدت أن البطالة تحدي أكبر
فعندك السياحة تتميز أنها توظّف من خريجين الجامعات والدراسات العليا
إلى حاملي الشهادات المهنية إلى الحرفيين
وتعطيهم فرص تطوير من أول السلم الوظيفي إلى أعلاه
واحنا طبعًا ما يخفي عليك تحدي البطالة
أكبر تحدي اقتصادي واجتماعي لنا
فالسياحة مو بس مثلها مثل أي قطاع
يتميز بعدد الوظائف ونوع الوظائف اللي يوفرها
وأخيرًا السياحة بتبني هوية المملكة
كل زائر يأتي للمملكة لأي غرضٍ كان
بيرجع يقول أنا صراحة متفاجئ ببلد المملكة العربية السعودية
وهذا التفاجئ سمعة، وهذه السمعة تزيد من الزوار
وتزيد من الرغبة في التعاون والتبادل الثقافي التجاري، أيًّ كان
ويمكن يخدمنا احنا في موضوع السمعة
أنه الإعلام ما قصّر عشرين سنة وهو يشوّه سمعتنا
فاحنا بادين بنقطة توقعات مرة متدنية
أي أحد يجي السعودية يطلع بانطباع إيجابي مو بالضرورة
لأن كل شيء تمام، بس لأن هو جاي بتوقعات مره متدنية
نتيجة العشرين سنة من ...
اسمح لي أختلف معك
تمام، تفضل
كثير يقولون إيه أصلًا سمعة المملكة سيئة فكانت...
مو سيئة مشوهة، سمعتها مشوهة من الإعلام
كانت مشوهة بمساوئ في أذهان الناس
لأن الإعلام الغربي كل اللي كان يهمه حروب وما زال
نشوف الإعلام ينقل عن الدول حروب، مظاهرات، مشاكل
يمكن صراع قوى سياسية، هذا اللي ينقله الإعلام بشكل عام
عمر الإعلام بينقلك، والله بنينا متاحف
وللا وظفنا مدري كم، وللا طورنا
لأن الإعلام ما يهتم بكل ما هو إيجابي
أنا أعتقد المملكة العربية السعودية صح قد تفاجئ البعض
إن كان عند الناس مفهوم سائد مشوّه
لكن الأهم، المملكة تفاجئ الزوار بالدرجة الأولى
هذا مو كلامي، هذا كلام عندي مرصود
بمجتمعهم وناسهم
لا، عندي موثّق بالبيانات
نحن نسوي استطلاعات للناس اللي تزور
السبب الأول، ما يقولك والله أني تفاجأت
السبب الأول هو المجتمع السعودي، السعودي والسعودية
مرحبين، لطيفين، كريمين، منفتحين
ما كنا نتوقع أبدًا هذا الشيء على كلامك
اثنين، ما قد شفنا هذا الترحاب وهذه الحفاوة
احنا على فكرة في الهيئة اخترنا مصطلح الحفاوة السعودية
كعنوان أصيل للضيافة العربية
الحفاوة تشمل أكثر من مفهوم
ثلاث مفاهيم رئيسية
أول وحدة الخدمة، إذا أنا بحتفي فيك وأنت جايني
بقدم لك أفضل خدمة لدي أعرفها
اثنين، بكرمك
ثلاثة، بهتم فيك، حتى لو يجيك طلب مالي أي دخل فيه
بقول كيف أساعدك؟ وكيف أهتم فيك؟
فالاهتمام والرعاية والخدمة والكرم
كلها تندرج تحت مصطلح الحفاوة
فالحفاوة السعودية ستعيد مفهوم الضيافة العربية الأصيلة
وهي في جيناتنا
أنت تتكلم على أيش هذه الثقافة اللي جزء من تعاليمها وعرفها
أنه يجيك الضيف الغريب، ثلاثة أيام ما تسأله أيش حاجتك
ثلاثة أيام تضيّفه، تستقبله، تكرمه
ما تفتح معه إطلاقًا ليش جيت؟ ومن أنت؟
أي ثقافة تصل بها درجة إكرام الضيف هذا المستوى؟
فاحنا عندنا هذا ...
واجبنا نحافظ عليه طال عمرك
الأجيال الجديدة يمكن كثير ما يستوعبون أهمية هذا الثقافة
أنا ممكن أقول لبنتي اعزمي فلانة وأهلها يجون عندك
شافتهم في الطيارة
وتقول لي بس بيستغربون
قلت لهم إيه خلهم يستغربون، بيستغربون بشيء إيجابي
خلهم يستغربون هذه ثقافتنا
صحيح
ونعتز فيها
هذا احنا
بيتفاجئون؟ بيخافون؟ معليش
بس في البداية بيعرفون أننا صادقين
وإذا جاوا، شافوا اللي ما شافوه في أي بلد ثاني
فموضوع السياحة هو قطاع اقتصادي مهم
فيه فرصة مهدرة بأننا فقط 3%
تنمية اقتصادية، توظيف
والصورة الذهنية اللي ما تسمى القوة الناعمة
طيب خلينا نسأل، ليش بهذا الهيكل؟
ليش وزارة في فبراير 2020 تحولت الهيئة السابقة إلى وزارة؟
وبعدين في مارس بعدها بشهر تأسست الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
وفيه صندوق تنمية السياحة، وفي مجلس الأعلى للسياحة أو شيء مثل كذا
ليش بهذا الهيكل؟
وأيش فرق أو دور كل واحد من هذا الهيكل؟
الوزارة هي من يقود القطاع، الوزارة معنية باستراتيجية القطاع
وهي دورها الرئيسي مشرّع
التراخيص، التصاريح، التفتيش، على كل الشركات
ومستوى الخدمات المقدمة للسياح
فنادق، شركات تنظيم رحلات على سبيل المثال
الهيئة
وأيضًا يبدو لي بناء القدرات
عفوًا، إذا تكلمت عن أهمية القطاع السياحي تكمن في التوظيف
فتطوير الكادر البشري والتوظيف هو يمكن
الدور الأهم
الهدف الأول والدور الأهم لدى هذه الوزارة
بالنسبة للهيئة هي الذراع التجاري المعني بثلاثة أدوار
التسويق والتشويق لزيارة المملكة
التسويق والتشويق
هذا واحدة، التسويق لكل الأغراض
أما بالنسبة للزيارة، مثلًا الزيارة الدينية نحن نبغى نشوّق حتى الأسر
اللي بأطفالهم يجوا ويعرفوا أبنائهم بمكة والمدينة
وما لديها من وجهات ومواقع تاريخية الكل يحب يطلع عليها
الدور الثاني، التوزيع
والتوزيع هذا يمكن الشق التجاري الأكبر والأهم
ما يمكن سائح يجي، إلا إذا فيه شركة وكالة للسفر والسياحة
إذا فيه شركة طيران، إذا فيه فنادق، فيه شركة تنظيم
إذا فيه منصات إلكترونية للحجز، وإلى آخره إلى المرشد
فبالتالي هذا من يعمل مع القطاع التجاري؟ هي الهيئة
الدور الثالث، قياس تجربة الزائر وتطويرها
هذا دور الهيئة
الدور الثالث، ذكرت أنت الصندوق
الصندوق يموّل كل المستثمرين من الكبار إلى الصغار ورواد الأعمال
في تطوير تجربة الزائر
نحن نروح للوزارة نقول لهم التجربة يبغى لها تطوير في هذا الجانب
مثلًا التأشيرات، نروح إلى وزارة السياحة
وزارة السياحة تعمل مع نظرائها من وزارة الخارجية والداخلية
لتطوير وتسهيل التأشيرات
نروح للصندوق، نقول نبغى نستثمر في تطوير
في التجارب الوطنية، تجارب العيش مثلًا في السكن
التجارب محلية، إن كان أكل محلي أو حتى إقامة في بيوت
ونُزل ريفية أو نُزل صحراوية، جبلية
فالصندوق يعمل على صناعة هذه التجارب مع القطاع الخاص
الجهاز الرابع، اللي هو مجلس التنمية السياحي
قبل ما أشرح لك مجلس التنمية السياحي أيش دوره
خلنا نقول لك تجربة السائح
تبدأ طال عمرك، يحجز تأشيرة
تطلع له من منصة وزارة الخارجية
يركب الطيارة اللي مرخصة له هيئة الطيران المدنية
يوصل للمطار، يتعامل مع الشركة وموظفي شركة
أو مطوري أو مشغلي المطارات
يختم جوازه عند الجوازات الداخلية
يركب «أوبر» وللا سيارة أجرة عند هيئة النقل
يروح للسوق عند وزارة التجارة، يروح للمتحف عند وزارة الثقافة
يروح يحضر حفل عند هيئة الترفيه
ينام في الفندق عند وزارة السياحة
فهذه السلسلة، مين بينظمها؟
مين بيتأكد أنها تعطي الأولويات اللي مهمة للسائح؟
احنا نروح للوزارة، والوزير هو رئيس مجلس التنمية السياحي
وعندنا كل الجهات التي تُعنى بهذا القطاع، اللي احنا نسميه قطاع
رحلة الزائر أو رحلة السائح
صحيح
فهذولي الأربع
قطاع أفقي، وليس عمودي
وهذولي منظومة السياحة، طيب فيه
وعفوًا معليش، بس لما أقول قطاع أفقي يعني لن تحقق مستهدفات القطاع
بمنظومة وحدة
إذا ما عالجت كل هذه الأشياء، فلو واحد منها نقص
حاس التجربة كلها
لا، التجربة كلها ...
لا، ترى جودةً وكمًا
طبعًا، 100%
هذه أدوار الناس جيرانكم، المنظومة
طيب فيه الحارة اللي جنبكم
أو أجهزة أخرى، ما احنا فاهمين كيف تتكامل معاكم؟
اللي هي مثلًا هيئات الثقافة، هيئة الترفيه، وزارة الرياضة
هذولي أيضًا يقيمون فعاليات سياحية، وأنشطة سياحية
بالضبط، أيش الفرق بينكم وبينهم ودوركم؟
أبدًا، أنا أقول لك لما تكلمت عن الجهات في الرحلة
لما يوصل الزائر يدوّر محتوى، مين صناع المحتوى؟
هم اللي وزارة الرياضة في كل الفعاليات الرياضية
من «فورميلا» إلى المباريات إلى تنس
حفلات، مواقع ترفيهية
ومنظومة الثقافة، صراحة اليوم اللي تقوم به منظومة الثقافة
جزء رئيس احنا مرتكزين عليه في الترويج للمملكة
من مواقع أثرية، من تنقيب إلى حفاظ على تراث ثقافي مادي وغير مادي
إلى إنتاج محتوى ثقافي يتفاعل مع الثقافات العالمية
فكلهم منتجي محتوى، واحنا دورنا أننا نستفيد من هذا المحتوى
ونسوّقه للعالم كلٍ بما يبحث عنه
فأنتم تجيبون الزبون، ثم هذه الهيئات المختلفة
تقدم تجارب مختلفة لهذا الزبون
صحيح
يمكن فيه أنت...
أو نروح للجهات هذه، ونقول لهم مثلًا نبغى نستقطب صينيين
فنتكلم الآن مع هيئة الترفيه على إنتاج محتوى جاذب
فالتعاون بيننا مو بس احنا نجيب الناس
بس نصنع محتوى يجذب الناس، ودورنا...
الشيء اللي أنتم مهتمين فيه
صح
يمكن أنت أبو التسويق، فتعرف أنه صعب تكون الأفضل في كل شيء
أو أنك تجي تنافس أحد مكوّش على الملعب حقه
فاحنا دخلنا للسياحة مرة متأخرين
يعني احنا نتكلم على عام 2019 فتحنا تأشيرة السياحة
والعالم واصل مراحل متقدمة في هذا المجال
أيش المقومات اللي تركز عليها السعودية للمنافسة العالمية؟
اليوم السائح عنده 196، ما نعرف كم دولة في الكرة الأرضية، كلهم يبغونه
نحن جايين متأخر مرة
على أيش نراهن لإقناع هذا السائح أنه يجي عندنا؟
ثلاث...
نقاط قوة
ثلاثة مساحات، كل مساحة أثرى من الثانية
المساحة الأولى، التنوّع
طال عمرك، التنوع الثقافي اللي عندنا، الجغرافي
نتكلم عن أفضل صحاري في العالم
أجمل تضاريس صحراوية في العالم عندنا
شوف كم من الناس اللي تبحث عن معسكرات الصحراء
احنا بيت التلال العربية العظيمة، هذه...
الخيام
لا، التلال الذهبية؛ احنا موطنها
وهذا ممكن في يوم تكون مثل «السفاري»
ومثل التزلج في أوربا، أو السفاري في أفريقيا
تعال للتنوع الثقافي، أتكلم عن الجبال
جبال «السروات» ومنطقة عسير
واليوم ما نقوم به من تطوير في الباحة وللا الطائف وللا القمم السوداء
هذا استغلال التضاريس، وما تقدمه هذا التضاريس
من أجواء باردة في منطقة تلتهب في الصيف
فنحن نتميز في فترة الصيف بهذا
بعدين عندك البحر الأحمر
وين تلقى شاطئ يمتد لأكثر من 1700 كيلومتر
بأندر الشعب المرجانية، وحياة فطرية بحرية
لا يمكن أن تجدها في أي مكان
ولذا «ناشونال جيوقرافيكس» بتقول
أن عندك مناطق غوص الأفضل في العالم
فهذا تنوع جغرافي
التنوع الثقافي في كل منطقة جغرافية وتضاريس مختلفة؛ تتشكل الثقافة
وبتلقى من أكل إلى لبس إلى
موروث
إلى فولكلور، بالضبط
السائح اليوم يبحث عن ما هو جديد
واحنا أفضل منطقة حافظنا عليها، واليوم نفتحها للعالم
وبعدين الأمر الثاني، أرض الجزيرة العربية
احنا الآن نقدّم السعودية كأرض الجزيرة العربية
هذه الأرض ماهي مثل أي أرض
هذه أرض حضارات، أنبياء
كل حضارة تركت لنا أرث مادي وغير مادي
اليوم لما تشوف المنظومة الثقافية
أقول لك فيه بعثتات أكثر من 27 بعثة
اللي هم يسوون البحث والتنقيب
نحتاج احنا ندوّر الشواهد المادية
الشواهد المادية هذه اللي بنقدمها للسائح
بس احنا بنتكلم عن قصص وموروث غير مادي
الشواهد المادية تكمّل القصة
وتعطيك مكان له عنوان؛ تزوره
فأعتقد
عندنا مقومات نقدر ننافس
ومثل ما قلت لك الحضارات والأنبياء
إلى مرورهم بالمملكة العربية السعودية
هذه أرض...
لما أقولك الأنبياء وطبعًا مهد الإسلام واللغة العربية
إلى المملكة العربية السعودية اللي بدأت من ثلاث قرون
إلى اليوم أنا كنت أقول أن المدن والدول
مثل كائن حي يستمر يعيش عنده موروث، لكن يطوّر
اليوم احنا بنصيغ الجزيرة العربية الحديثة
وبنبني مستقبل الجزيرة العربية
وبتكون حضارة ترصدها دول وشعوب أخرى
فعندنا الكثير من ما تركته لنا هذه الحضارات، نقدمه
ثلاثة، قاعدين نبني وجهات
استفادت من كل أخطاء الوجهات العالمية الأخرى
اليوم أنا ما أتكلم بس عن الغير مسبوق مثل «نيوم»
فيه فكر وتخطيط وإمكانات
حتى في العُلا، حتى في عسير
فيه أخطاء كثير شفناها في الدول سبقتنا
واحنا نقول عندنا المشاريع العملاقة
ترى هذه مسؤوليات عملاقة
لأننا بنبني مستفيدين من أخطاء الغير
والحمدلله القيادة ملتزمة، بأن لن نضحي بالبيئة
لن نضحي بالطبيعة، وبالعكس وسنأتي ونطوّر وجهات
ونعيدها إلى ما كانت في عقود وقرون مضت
يعني اليوم المحميات أكبر دليل في كيفية إعادة ...
ماني متأكد من الترجمة
إعادة الحياة الفطرية
بالضبط
وأنت بتشوف كم بدينا في العُلا، وملتزمين بأكثر من 21 كائن حي
بنعيد بناء الحياة الفطرية لهم، واستقطابهم إلى الأرض
اللي كانوا فيها قبل مئات وقرون السنين
الآن فهمنا ليش مهم موضوع السياحة
وعندنا مقومات
وعندنا مقومات، والهيكل حقنا
تعال شوي ندخل
بس عفوًا، أبغى أقول رغم أن هذه القوانين الثلاثة
شوف هذه الثلاثة مثل إذا بقول
الثلاث طبقات اللي يربطها كلها هو الإنسان السعودي
الحفاوة تحديدًا، الحفاوة السعودية اللي لا بد أنه نعززها ونحافظ عليها
ونستمر في إحيائها، وتكريم أفضل الأمثلة لمن يحييها
100% وهذ أتوقع يجي دور هنا الأفلام ويجي دور السينما
والجوائز
ورواة القصص بأشكالها المختلفة في كتب، أفلام، مسلسلات
الكرم الأصيل،الكرم السعودي اللي عبر التاريخ
كرم إنسان الجزيرة العربية
هذا إلى الآن لم يعطى حقه
وفيه قصص مذهلة
أنا أتذكر قبل شهرين كنت في حائل
حائل من المناطق السعودية اللي اشتهرت بالكرم تاريخيًا
وحتى في الوقت المعاصر
وهم موطن «حاتم الطائي» رمز الكرم العربي
فيسولف لي صديقي «نادر الشمري»
عن الفخذ اللي هو ينتمي له
وكيف أنهم كانوا مجموعة وطالعين مع بعض
وراح أحد منهم يبحث عن الماء، انقطعوا فترة معينة
فانتصف في الطريق، ورجع ما كمّل الوصول للمويا
قال أخاف أوصل واشرب وارجع
وألقاكم متوا؛ يقولون ترك أخوياه
فأنا لا يمكن أشرب إلا لو واحنا سوى، فرجع لربعه
فيه شواهد وقصص، تقدر تطلع منها أنت وترويها
وهذه هي وسيلة تعزيز هذه القيم، وتثبيتها في الأجيال الجديدة
لأن الجيل الجديد قد يكون مفصول نوعًا ما عن هذه القصص
وإن شاء الله أنها تبدأ تتعزز منها
بس هنا بسأل بشوية عن الهيئة نفسها
خلصنا الكلام الحلو، الحين وسّع صدرك معاي
ببدأ الكلام اللي يمكن نتناقش فيه أكثر
عفوًا ممكن قبل ما تسألني أنا أبغى أقول أن التسويق
ليس على مستوى مدن فقط حتى على مستوى فعاليات
له دور مرة كبير
أنت تعرف في السعودية كان الكثير يسافرون لفعاليات
اليوم الفعاليات كلها موجودة
بداية رأس السنة، كثير كانوا يسافرون عشان رأس السنة
اليوم الناس تترقب رأس السنة
بس الأهم شوف أيش سوينا في اليوم الوطني؟
الناس تترقب اليوم الوطني بفعالياته
يوم التأسيس، كيف بنيناه
كرنفال ثقافي عظيم
بالضبط، الناس تستناه
ويوم العلم قادم إن شاء الله
فالتسويق على كل المستويات، على مستوى الدول
على مستوى المدن، على مستوى المراكز، وعلى مستوى الفعاليات
تفضل
دائمًا لما احكي عن الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
وآسف تحملني
الناس يقولون يا أخي، الله يعطيهم العافية
بس أحس أنهم ملخبطين، يا أخي أحس ماهم مرتبين
فجأة تلاقي لوح إعلانات «روح السعودية»
في مكان ماله دخل، أو يمكن ما نستهدف الشريحة هذه
أو ما أحد يناظر الأماكن هذه بالتكلفة هذه
وبندخل على المشاهير اللي توقعون معاهم، وتجيبونهم
بس ودي تعرفنا على أيش بالضبط سوّت الهيئة من يوم ما بدأت كأثر؟
وليش هذا الانطباع عنكم؟
أولًا أنا ما أدري أنت مين تكلم، لكن بفترض أن هذا انطباع
لا شوف، موضوع التسويق
في كل وظيفة أو مكان عمل أنا اشتغلت فيه
مساحة يفتي فيها كل واحد، التسويق والإعلام
لأن مين تكلمون؟ أنا أدرى وأعرف
احنا ندّعي إننا تقنيين جدًّا في ما نقوم به من تسويق
وعندنا قياس لـ 32 ألف مستهدف سنويًا
نقيس انطباعاتهم عن المملكة العربية السعودية
ورغبتهم في الزيارة، واستعدادهم للحجز، ونيتهم للحجز أكثر من مستوى
لأن الاستعداد شيء، طيب استعديت؛ هل نويت؟
أنا ممكن أقول لك، قد رحت المالديف؟
إيه
أول ما سمعت عنها، هل على طول راحت؟ وللا قعدت فترة؟
لا، قعدت فترة
مثل أي منتج يُطرح
احنا الآن في الساحة السياحية
طُرح منتج جديد اسمه السعودية
هل إذا دريت عنه بتروح؟
لا، بتقول يبغى لي أفكر
أو يمكن تقول لا السعودية ما أعتقد أنها لي
والله مستغرب، والله شفت
لا، ممكن
آه نويت أخطط، آه لا مو السنة دي
إن شاء الله السنة اللي بعدها
فالآن اللي يقولون ليش تسوقون من الآن؟
ترى المملكة ماهي جاهزة
ترى مشوار القرار يعني العزم والنية والحجز
ما يأتي إلا بعد سابع نية حجز
أوه!
عالميًا
تجي بعدين تتكلم عن اللي ما قد زاروا
ما أتكلم عن دول الجوار، واللي قد زاروا كثير
اثنين، الناس تقول يا أخي ليش تعلن في هذا الوقت؟
مين بيجيك في هذا الوقت؟
الوقت بالنسبة لنا هو فترة الحجز أو ما يسمى نافذة الحجز
كل بلد لها نافذة حجز مختلفة
نافذة الحجز يعتمد على الجداول الدراسية
ويعتمد على القرب، وعلى العادات عندهم
عطني مثال
أعطيك مثال، الخليج يقرروا في خلال أسبوعين أو ثلاثة يروحون
اليابانيين يأخذون ثمانية شهور
أمريكا أربعة شهور يعني نافذة الحجز
إذا ما جيتهم قبله بأربع شهور ما هم بجايينك
فبالتالي أنت في منظورك قد ترى أنه مو هذا الوقت
أول تكلمت عن الإنفاق، الثانية الوقت
الثالث، المحتوى
هل هذا هو المحتوى؟
لذلك احنا نسوي اختبار داخل مجموعات 130 شخص
ونعرض عليهم صور، ونقول لهم أيش شفتوا؟
أيش عجبكم؟ هل يحفزكم وللا لا؟
نفس الشخص نعرض عليه من 5-6 صور
ونشوف أيش اللي يحركه
الصيني يختلف عن البلجيكي، والمرأة غير الرجل
والأم غير الشابة، وكبار السن غير...
عشان كذا لما تشوف الإعلان ينقص ويتقطع
يعني لما نصوّر إعلان نطلّع 52 نسخة
عشر ثواني، ست ثواني
طبعًا حسب القناة، وحسب المستهدف، وحسب التاريخ
فأنا أقصد، مو الكل يدرك...
وأنت أيش قلت؟
قلت إنفاق، توقيت، محتوى
وقلنا بشكل عام أن الناس تشوف كأن فيه عدم ترتيب
في شغل الهيئة بشكل عام
ما أدري كيف وصل لهم هذا الانطباع؟
هل لأن مثلًا تنشافون في الخارج
بعدين تنشافون في معارض، بعدين تنشافون جايبين لاعب
إيه صح في الخارج
لو تشرح لنا
باختصار ترى احنا لا بد أن نكون
في كل مكان
هو الشخص متعود
«عكوز بكوز»
أن أنت هيئة، خلاص وريني شغلك وأقعد فيه
إيه
أنا سمعة بلد
تقول لي وين أطلع باسم الهيئة السعودية؟
أنا ما أطلع باسم الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
أنا أطلع باسم «روح السعودية»
وبالتالي هذا شعار المملكة اللي نسوّق فيه
كل من يقوم وينتج كل محتوى، أو يبني كل وجهة
أو يتعاقد مع أي لاعب
ترى على فكرة مو احنا اللي نتعاقد مع اللعيبة
بنجيها، لا اصبر
هذه لا تمررها لي كذا بسرعة
عشان أقولك بس
هذه بنقعد نأخذ راحتنا فيها
لا، أنا أقصد اللي يشوف يمكن هذا الانطباع يأتي
من عدم استيعاب أن هذه الهيئة أيش دخلها في ذا، وأيش دخلها في ذا
لا بالعكس، الهيئة لا بد أنها تقتنص كل ما هو جديد
من محتوى ومنتج ووجهة وتجربة؛ للترويج عنها لاستقطاب السياح
طيب، أيش سويتوا؟
أيش حققتوا من يوم ما بديتوا إلى اليوم؟
جميل، طبعًا لما بدينا وأطلقنا الاستراتيجية
أعلنا عن مستهدف 100 مليون زائر أو زيارة بنهاية 2030
ما زال البعض ماهو واضح له أيش معنى زيارة
زيارة يعني المبيت ليلة وحدة في المملكة العربية السعودية
أو في أي مدينة يسافر لها
إذا كان فيها مبيت
عفوًا، هدف الـ100 مليون، أنت تتكلم 100 مليون زيارة
من الداخل والخارج، وللا بس من الخارج؟
من الداخل والخارج
ويوم أعلناه كم كنا واصلين؟
54 مليون
54 مليون؟
صحيح
فأنت كنت تبغى تضاعف الرقم خلال عشر سنوات؟
نعم
تمام، اسلم
طبعًا علمًا أننا كنا باديين
نتكلم عن أغراض الزيارة كلها
الزيارات الدينية، زيارات الأعمال، زيارات الأهل والأصدقاء
والزيارات اللي نعرفها السياحية، اللي هي زيارة المتعة
إن كان استجمام، وللا ثقافة، وللا رياضة، وللا أيًّ كان
فمن 2018 حطينا مستهدفات لكل أنواع الزيارة
زيارة محلية داخلية وزيارة خارجية
بالنسبة لنا الزيارة الداخلية كانت أحد أهم نقاط التركيز
لأنهم المفروض أول ناس نبدأ فيهم، لأكثر من سبب
إذا ما أقنعته هو، ما أنت مقنع اللي برّا
إذا ما أقنعت اللي هنا عندك
بالضبط، وخاصةً وهذا السبب الثاني
أن السائح السعودي الأعلى إنفاقًا في العالم
ثلاثة، السائح السعودي، بيقنع المستثمر السعودي أنه يستثمر
لأن فيه طلب محلي
لما تقفل الأبواب مثل ما صار في الجائحة
أو لأي شأن أمني أو سياسي أو أيًّ كان
الاقتصاد هذا سيقاوم بما لديه من سياحة داخلية
وإذا كان المستثمر المحلي استثمر
بيجيك المستثمر الأجنبي ويقول أنا بدخل وأشارك وأبني على ما لديك
فالسياحة الداخلية كانت أكبر هدف لنا أو أول هدف لنا
والكثير كان يتحدى
يقول أن أول ما تفتح الأبواب بعد الجائحة
الناس كلها بتهج وبتسافر
صحيح في 2018؟
الجائحة 2020- 2021
فتحت الدنيا، كيف الأمور؟
اليوم السائح أقدر أقول لك في 2022
السائح المحلي وصل إلى 77 مليون زيارة
الزيادة السنوية بإضطراد
وأعتقد أن هذا بيخلينا نعيد النظر في الهدف
أصلًا صراحة الهدف ماهو بطموح
إذا احنا قبل التأشيرة، وقبل المشاريع الكبرى
وقبل العُلا وقبل الدنيا هذه 54
معقولة هدفنا في 12 سنة بس نضاعف هذا الرقم؟
ماهو بهذا العشم في أهداف السعودية
عادةً الناس يقولون أصلًا أهداف مبالغ فيها
وللا أهداف أفلاطونية، كذا دائمًا توسم أهداف السعودية
فغريب شلون مررتوا الهدف البسيط هذا؟
لا أبدًا ما هو بسيط
لأن المعيار الحقيقي ليس بالعدد، هو الأثر للعدد
والأثر يأتي من العدد ومعدل الإنفاق
فالحقيقة النجاح الحقيقي أنك تأتي بضعف
لكن نوع هذا الضعف وتشكيلة هذه الفئات
اللي أنت تستقطبها هي اللي بتدفع وتنفق في بلدك
أكبر بكثير من الخمسين الأولى
طيب فكّك لنا هذا الرقم أبو سارة، وقل لنا
بالضبط أيش كان دوركم فيه؟
لأن فيه ناس يقولون أغلب هذا الرقم جاي من المعتمرين
واللي هم الله يخليهم لنا موجودين من زمان
قبل ما أنتم تجون، وقبل ما تسوون أي شيء
فأيش هذا دوركم أنتم في الـ 54 اللي صارت 93 مليون؟
أولًا شكرًا على هذا السؤال
فعلًا هذا السؤال يجيني في المجالس، ويجيني من الكل
طال عمرك، احنا لما تكلمنا عن الـ 100 مليون زيارة
كنا نتكلم عن كل الزيارات لكافة الأغراض
من الداخل ومن الخارج
كما ذكرت أنت كنا 54 مليون زيارة
الزيارة تُعرّف بأنه الإنسان يسافر إلى مدينة
ويبيت فيها لو ليلة واحدة هذه تعد زيارة
بالنسبة لنا الأغراض تشمل كافة الأغراض الأربعة
إن كانت سياحة، اللي هي تسألني عنها
مثلًا السياحة يعني المتعة، استجمام، رياضة، ثقافة، بحر، أيًّ كان
أو زيارة لغرض الأعمال، أو زيارة لغرض زيارة الأهل والأصدقاء، أو الزيارة الدينية
واحنا تشرفنا بخدمة ضيوف الرحمن وخدمة الحرمين
ولا بد أننا نبدأ بهذا كأولوية، أننا نرفع هذا العدد
وللا الرؤية نصت على مستهدف أنه نرفع عدد الزوار المعتمرين
ما أتكلم عن الحج، المعتمرين إلى 30 مليون زائر بنهاية 2030
الآن المعتمرين، أيش دورنا فيه؟
نحن بالنسبة للهيئة عندنا ثلاث أدوار رئيسية
كزائر عندك سمعة، واحنا مسؤوليتنا تطوير السمعة
اليوم تطوير السمعة أو تحسين السمعة عن تجربة العمرة
ما كان أحد يتكلم عنها
ما كان أحد يتكلم عن تسهيلات التأشيرات بوضوح
أو تطوير المطارات، أو قطار الحرمين إلى آخره
كل ما أصبح يسير، ما زال في أذهان الكثير عسير
فيما يخص تجربة العمرة
هذا دور أول، وأطلقنا منصة «نسك» في الدور الأول
أطلقنا منصة «نسك» اللي تحاكي منصة «روح السعودية»
لأنك أنت تبغى تطلّع، وتعرف معلومات
تعريف وتشويق، وتساعدك على التخطيط
للأغراض كلها حطينا «روح السعودية»
ولغرض زيارة مكة والمدينة حطينا منصة «نسك دوت إس إيه»
بالتعاون مع وزارة الحج والعمرة وبرنامج ضيوف الرحمن
الدور الثاني، كان تطوير الخطوط الجوية عبر الناقلات الوطنية والعالمية
وسيّرنا رحلات وخطوط جديدة ما كانت موجودة
وزدنا عدد المقاعد
الثالث، هو تطوير ومساعدة الشركات وسلاسل الإمداد
الشركات المقصود بها وكالات السفر والسياحة، منصات الحجز
شركات تنظيم الرحلات وشركات تنظيم العمرة
ترى هذولا ما كان عندهم أحد يدعمهم ويوجههم ويساعدهم في التطوير
اليوم فيما يخص زيارة العمرة
احنا اشتغلنا مع كافة الشركات في هذه السلسلة
وساعدناهم في تطوير باقات للترويج لباقاتهم
والوصول من خلال شركات الطيران وين منصات الحجز الدولية
الآن، هل فيه زائر يأتي لغرض واحد؟
أقول لك أغلبهم لا
الغالب يجي إن كان أعمال ، ويروح يتفسّح
وفي حالتنا إن كان مسلم يجي للأعمال وبعدين يعتمر
فبالتالي فيه تداخل بين الزيارات
لذا الآن، احنا وحدنا الزيارة وأعلنا عن التأشيرة الجديدة
تأشيرة زيارة موحدة لأي غرضٍ كان
فدورنا يشمل كل هذه الأدوار
وعلينا مستهدف لرفع عدد المعتمرين
مثل ما علينا رفع عدد الزيارات بأغراضها المختلفة
بس خلينا نمسك الأرقام أبو سارة
تفضل
كم زاد عدد المعتمرين؟
كم زاد عدد الزائرين من الخارج
اللي هما نوعًا ما التحدي الجديد أو المهمة الجديدة عليكم
لأن بقية الأغراض كانت موجودة قبلكم ومستمرة
يمكن سهّلتوا شوي في التأشيرات
لكن الرهان الحقيقي أنك تقنع واحد
ما كان يخطط يجي للسعودية، أنه يجي
حقين الأعمال من زمان ودهم يجون، بس كان الباب مقفل
العمرة قائمة ومستمرة
لكن الزائر اللي من برّا، كم كنا وكم صرنا؟
وهل فرق هذا في موضوع الأثر الاقتصادي
اللي كنا نحكي فيه في بداية الحلقة؟
شوف احنا عندنا هدف تمديد مدة البقاء لكل الأغراض
وبالنسبة لزيارة المتعة والسياحة أننا نستحدث هذه ونجذب
ونأتي بأرقام ونرفع الأرقام
الآن اليوم عدد الزوار من الخارج في عام 2022 انتهينا بـ 16.5 مليون
المستهدف للعام القادم 25 مليون
احنا اليوم في منتصف العام
احنا بنصوّر في منتصف العام
والحمدلله تخطينا 12 مليون
عساس نوصل إن شاء الله إلى 25 مليون
انتقالًا من 16.5 مليون العام الماضي
هذه الزيارة وليس السائح
هذه الزيارة
بالتعريف اللي اتفقنا عليه
بالضبط، لكل الأغراض وكلها في زيادة
وعندنا أهداف لكل غرض
كم كان رقم خط الأساس؟
في 2018 كان 54 مليون زيارة
منها 8 مليون من الخارج
8 مليون
لكل الأغراض
اليوم في الـ 8 مليون اللي كانت وقت بدايتكم
اليوم صارت في آخر سنة 16 مليون
ومستهدفين السنة هذه 25 مليون زيارة من الخارج
صحيح
طيب بنسبة للإنفاق؟
أنا أعتقد الإنفاق هو المعيار الحقيقي للنجاح
لأن إذا ما زاد العدد، وزاد الإنفاق
هذا بحد ذاته أفضل نجاح، ليش؟
لأن تجربة الزائر ما بتخرب بازدحام في المواقع أو ازدحام مروري
أو إزدحام أيًّ كان في المطارات
فعشان كذا لو تشوف المعيار الحقيقي للنجاح
كم زاد الإنفاق وكم المستهدف بنهاية 2030؟
بدينا طال عمرك بـ 165 مليار إنفاق في عام 2018
هذا إنفاق من؟ كل الزائرين؟
كل الزوار
داخل وخارج
والمستهدف بنهاية 2030 هو 561
أتكلم عن أكثر من ثلاثة أضعاف
بينما الزيادة في العدد من 50 مليون إلى 100 مليون
الإنفاق المفروض أنه يكون أكثر من ثلاثة أضعاف
معناته النجاح مش استقطاب مثل العدد
وإنما تغيير الفئة المستهدفة، ومعدل الإنفاق
ونوع السائح، وغرض الزيارة
واليوم احنا كم وصلنا في هذا الإنفاق؟
في عام 2022 ارتفعنا إلى 184 مليار
وما كان فيه حج، يعني لو تضيف هذاك 165 شاملة للحج
فالزيادة لكنها طفيفة نظرًا لأن الحج ما كان بالأعداد بالطبيعية
صحيح
لما نقول هدف 100 مليون وأنت اليوم واصل 93 مليون زيارة
قبلما تفتح المشاريع الكبرى، وقبلما يستأنف قطاع السياحة
طاقته الكاملة بعد الجائحة
غريبة شلون مررتوا الهدف الغير طموح هذا؟
احنا متعودين أهداف الرؤية طموحة جدًّا أقرب إلى الخيال
أقرب إلى صعوبة التحقيق، يسمونها أهداف أفلاطونية من كثر ما هي صعبة
شلون أنتم مررتوا هدف بس أنكم تضاعفون مرة واحدة في عشر سنوات؟
غريبة هذه!
أولًا احنا العدد كان كبير، لأن عندك عمرة، وعندك أعمال مثل ما ذكرت
والمملكة فيها أهل وأصدقاء وزيارة أهل وأصدقاء مرتفعة
فالخط الأساسي اللي بدينا به نوعًا ما مرتفع
والـ 100 مليون بيحطنا من مصاف أفضل خمس دول في العالم
فقد لا يكون أفلاطوني في نظرك
لكن كون أننا نكون من مصاف أفضل خمس دول في العالم
هذا بحد ذاته معيار
الأمور تقاس بالتقييم وبالقياس
فاليوم تقيس بالدول الثانية تشوف أن الرقم كبير
ولكن تطمن، الرقم بيزيد
الرقم بيزيد؟
إيه، أنا أعتقد ومتأكد أن ما أحد كان متوقع الزيادة الكبيرة
في الزيارة المحلية، السياحة المحلية
نحن نتحدث عن 93 مليون العام الماضي
77 مليون منها من الداخل
الآن، السياحة الداخلية أنا ذكرت لك أنها الأهم
لأن السعودي هو الأعلى إنفاقًا في العالم
ولأن السعودي متطلب ويرفع الجودة
وأكثر واحد إذا ما عجبته الخدمة بيخرشهم ويقولك ضبّط الخدمة
وبيشرشحك في الإعلام الاجتماعي
فبالتالي السياحة الداخلية نموها الغير متوقع
هذا بحد ذاته نجاح كبير
لسببين، واحد فيه إنفاق محلي
والناس تقول أن الداخل أهم من إعادة تدوير الاقتصاد الداخلي
هذا ترى ما كان معه إعادة تدوير، هذا كان بيطلع برّا
فاحنا الآن حافظنا عليه، وشجعنا القطاع الخاص للاستثمار
نحن نتكلم على موضوع جهودكم بشكل عام
قفلنا سالفة الأرقام وأيش حققتوا في زيادة الزوار
أبغاك الحين تنتقل للجزء الثاني أو الملف الثاني
اللي هو أيش سويتوا في موضوع القطاع
وتمكين الشركات وتوزيع هذا الطلب اللي قاعدين تجيبونه
أيش كان الأثر على شركات القطاع، على الجهات العاملة في القطاع؟
يمكن أنت سألتني عن مشاركاتنا والمعارض الدولية
أول معرض دولي رحنا فيه كان سوق السفر العربي «إيه تي إم»
رحنا معنا 19 شركة، والشركات هذه أو جهة
من وجهات أو شركات تنظيم رحلات
بعد سنتين ونص، رحنا في الـ «آي تي بي» في برلين
كان معنا سبعين شركة، بس الأهم
أننا مكننا الشركات أنها توقّع عقود
لأن كل وكالات السفر العالمية تروح لهذه المعارض الدولية
عشان تشوف أيش عندك غرف، أيش عندك تجارب
وأيش عندك مقاعد على الطيران
فلما نروح المعارض الدولية
نأخذ خطوط الطيران ونأخذ الفنادق
ونأخذ شركات تنظيم الرحلات
نقدم كل ما لدينا في المملكة من منتجات سياحية توفر كامل التجربة
ويجي الوكيل الخارجي يشتري ويحجز
شركات تنظيم الرحلات، لا كان عندهم منصات إلكترونية
الفنادق ما كان عندهم مدراء مبيعات
ترى مدراء المبيعات في الفنادق عندنا
كلهم مدراء مبيعات للقاعات وأفراح وكذا
تعال وريني تسعيرة الغرف حقك لبعد 6 شهور، بعد سنة إلى 18 شهر
اللي يطلبوه الشركات؛ ما عندهم
خطوط الطيران ما كانوا كلهم يشاركون معنا
وإذا راحوا يشاركوا، يشاركوا بمعرض كبير جميل يتكلموا عن الكراسي
بس طيب وين الخطوط؟
فاليوم أنت تشوف الانتفاضة في القطاع والنمو الهائل في الشركات
والمشاركة انعكست في كم العقود اللي يتوقع في كل هذا المعرض
والحمدلله المملكة في كل معرض بتحقق إنجاز أفضل من اللي قبله
آخر واحد كان في برلين
كنا نطلب بعض الاجتماعات في السنوات اللي راحت
وما نقدر نحصل على لقاء المسؤولين الكبار
إن كانوا رؤساء مجالس خطوط أو رؤساء مجالس شركات سفر وإعلان
بدون ذكر أسماء أقدر أقول لك في برلين
اعتذرت من كثير من بعض الشركاء اللي جاوا في آخر لحظة
ورئيس مجلس إدارة إحدى الخطوط
جاني للمعرض يقول أدري أنك مشغول، لو أقابلك بس خمس دقايق
فالحمدلله في هذه الرحلة البسيطة في تعاملنا مع الشركات عالميًا
أقدر أقول لك أنه انتقلوا من ناس كانت تمر وتطنش وتمشي
ونحاول وندعوهم وما يجتمعون معنا
إلى تمر وتراقب أيش قاعدة تسوي السعودية؟
إلى اليوم تجي وتنتظر وتعمل معنا
وهذه خلال سنتين ونصف مشاركاتكم في المعارض
والمشاركات اللي قاعدين تسوونها مع الجهات المختلفة
لأن الدور الثاني مثل ما قلت استقطاب السياح وتكلمنا عن الأرقام
الدور الثاني هو التوزيع وسلاسل الإمداد
من خلال تطوير ما تقدمه شركات القطاع الخاص
من ضمن الجهود حسب ما سولفنا في حلقة سابقة
مع معالي رئيس الطيران المدني
موضوع تحفيز الخطوط على تسيير رحلات
الربط الجوي
هذه أيضًا كان لكم جهود فيها، لو تسولف لنا عنها
إيه الهيئة طال عمرك هي المطلوب منها تحدد الوجهات أو المدن
اللي مفروض الرابط الجوي يركز عليها ويبدأ فيها
الهيئة عندها دراسات تقدمها لبرنامج الربط الجوي
بناءً على معدل الطلب من هذه المدينة ونسبة استعداد الناس
أنا كنت أقول لك أنه نقيس سنويًا 32 ألف شخص في مدن مختلفة، 27 مدينة
ونتابع كل 6 شهور
بناءً على الأرقام، نقول الطلب المتوقع من هذه المدينة
يغطي مثلًا أربع رحلات إضافية من هذه المدينة
من الولايات المتحدة، من بربينقهام، من قلاسكو، أيًّ كان
فاحنا نروح لبرنامج الربط الجوي، ونعطي التوصية
أنه هذه الخطوط اللي نحتاجها كأولوية
ونبدأ، أي من الشركات
بس هذه التوصيات ترى مو محدودة بس
للخطوط اللي نبغى نربط عليها
كمان التوصيات اللي تروح لمنظومة السياحة
لأن برنامج الربط الجوي انبثق من استراتيجية السياحة
فنروح لوزارة السياحة، أوصي بتسهيل مثلًا التأشيرات
أو نوصي بتطوير مثلًا الكادر البشري لهذه الدولة
أو نروح مثلًا نطوّر الوجهات السياحية
مثلًا اليوم تجي لمدينة مثل الرياض
الكثير يتكلم عن التحديات اللي يواجهها في المدينة في الطرق
في الطرق المرورية إن كانت سواقة ولا زحام
وهذا يتكرر في عسير في موسم الصيف
فالآن الزحام أحد أهم العوائق عندنا للتنمية السياحية
فالآن كيف تعالجها؟
هنا ما بتتكلم عن النقل، بتتكلم عن تخطيط الوجهات
فاليوم لو تروح أي مدينة مثل لندن تلقى فيه أحياء سياحية
هذه الأحياء تقدر تقول أحياء متكاملة، فيها كل الخدمات
فأنا أطلب وأوصي لوزارة السياحة
أنه في تطوير الوجهات؛ نحتاج أحياء متكاملة
مثلًا الرياض، الدرعية بيكون حي متكامل
القدِّية
وين فيه عندنا أحياء؟
لا، حتى في الرياض التحلية مثلًا يمكن يكون فيه فنادق، معارض، مطاعم تنزل
«الرياض بوليفارد» اللي قامت به هيئة الترفيه
اليوم بدوا يحطوا فنادق، فبتتحول إلى أحياء متكاملة
كمان كل مدينة عندها فرصة أنها تبني أحياء متكاملة تستقطب السياح
تنزل فيه، تتمشى فيه، تأكل فيه، تشتري فيه
عساس ما تضيع وقتك في الزحام
كان لكم دور في موضوع خطوط الطيران «وز»
صحيح
دخلنا الموقع حقهم في الوجهات اللي يوصون بها
أو اللي يسوقونها وما لقينا ولا وجهة سعودية في الموقع حقهم
ما أدري مين اللي دخل، بس أنا أقدر أقول لك الأرقام
مسوين تصوير للشاشة وما لقينا أي وجهة سعودية ضمن الخيارات الأولى
متى هذا؟
هذا الكلام إلى قبل تصوير الحلقة بساعات
طيب أبشر نحاسبهم، بس المهم علي أداءهم
اليوم إذا فيه خط غير ناجح، والنجاح تعدّى 77% من المقاعد مليانة
إذا كان المقاعد مليانة، ليش أحط فلوس أسوّق؟
اليوم عندنا معدلات تفوق 94%
ما يحتاج تروج لهذه الخطوط
نحن اشتغلنا معهم ثلاثة وعشرين خط
من الثلاثة وعشرين خط، أربعة خطوط فقط اللي تحتاج تسويق
اثنين منها من إيطاليا
لو ترجع للموقع حقهم قبل شهرين، أطلقنا معهم رحلة عمياء
الرحلة العمياء أنك بس تسافر عمياني
طلعنا 100 مسافر مع طيران «وز»
100 مسافر ما يدرون وين بيروحون
وفي الواقع موجود الفيلم في الموقع حقهم
لأن هم اللي اشتغلوا معنا، وهم اللي راحوا للمطارات
وأقنعوهم أن السائح بيجي وموقّع ما يدري وين بيروح
فلازم نخفي في الشاشة، بنقول رحلة رقم كذا
الوجهة غير معروفة، بوابة رقم كذا
وسوّوها في مطارين
وجاؤوا الـ 100 سائح بعوائلهم بأطفالهم ومشيناهم
واليوم هذه الأربع خطوط بإذن الله تصل
المتوسط الآن على 77% من الأشغال
بقولك فيه بعض الزملاء يقولون
ترى يا أخي هذا الطيران قاعد يشيل ناس، ما يجيب ناس
أقول لك 70% من الحجوزات على طيران «وز» من خارج المملكة
بس الأهم، احنا ما نعطي حافز على المقعد اللي يتعبى من الداخل
احنا نعطي حافز فقط على المقعد اللي جاي
وهم عليهم يعبوا ...
فيه كلام كثير أبو سارة على أنه ترى مستعجلين احنا
قاعدين نسوّق، ونفتح البيبان، ونروّج للسياحة السعودية
واحنا ما بعد جهزنا، لا البنية التحتية جهزت
لا المنتجعات حقت الدرعية، والبحر الأحمر والعُلا اكتملت
قاعدين نخسر الفرصة حقت أن هذا إذا جاءك، بيجيك أول مرة
فإذا ما أنت جاهز، خلاص أنت خسرت الانطباع الأول، ورجع زعلان
وشفنا بعض الناس صوّر مقاطع في أماكن ماهي مريحة
بعض الناس صوّر مواقع لمواقف ما هي مريحة مع سائق أجرة
هل استعجلنا بترويج السياحة السعودية؟
الإجابة أبدًا ما استعجلنا
والكلام مو برأيي هو رأي السائح حال خروجه من المملكة
احنا عندنا قلت لك ثلاثة دور للهيئة
الدور الأول، استقطاب السياح والترويج
الدور الثاني، اللي هو تطوير سلاسل الإمداد مع القطاع الخاص
الدور الثالث، هو اللي يُعنى بما ذكرت
تجربة الزائر أو السائح
التجربة تقيس نقاط الالتقاء بالوجهة في 220 نقطة
يعني ركب الطيارة، دخل الطيارة، وصل للجوازات
ركب السيارة، في المطار، نقاط التقاء مختلفة
أخّر العفش، فاحنا نقيس 220 نقطة التقاء
ونشوف في الأخير، نأخذ 4000 شهريًا عشوائي
على كل مدينة زاروها أجانب ونسألهم
فيه مصطلح اسمه «إن بي إس» صافي نقاط الترويج
«نت» بمعنى الزبدة
«ترويج» بتروّج أو بتنصح بهذه الوجهة وللا لا؟
إذا كان انطباعك سيء
ما بتنصح فيها
إذا كان الـ«إن بي إس» بالسالب، نوقّف
إجابةً لمن يسأل هذا السؤال، ما وصلنا سالب
وصلنا في فترة الصيف كنا نروّج لإحدى المدن وكانت النتيجة بالسالب
وقّفت
وكان فيه يعني...
مقاومة
خاصةً المنطقة وأهلها وتجارها
كانوا يقولون وصلت إلى المسؤولين في المنطقة
أنه كيف تشيلونا من ...
أيش المنطقة هذه؟
ماني قايل، بس وقفناها وقلنا الصيف الجاي؛ نجهّز
أيش كانت مشكلة السياح؟
كانت المشكلة الحر
الحر؟
ولا كان فيه تجارب مغلقة أو مسقوفة أو كذا
خاصةً في المواقع اللي كنا بنروّج لها
وطورناها وفتحناها، والآن الـ «إن بي إس» بالإيجاب
وإجمالًا كم كانت درجاتنا أو أرقامنا في هذا المؤشر؟
هو أنت تقيس بالسالب إلى 50 هو 100
من 0 نيوترن أنصح فيها وللا ما أنصح فيها، ما أدري والله
إذا كان بالسالب، لا
إذا وصلت إلى 50- فأنتبه
تحذير من الزيارة
بالضبط، وأضع جهد أني أقول للناس انتبهوا لا أحد يروح
شباب، ترى هذا اللي صار لي، لا أحد يروح
إلى 50+
واحنا الآن...
طبعًا تتراوح لغرض السياحة والشريحة ومن أي بلد
لكن على المتوسط أقدر أقول احنا بالموجب من 11-24
من 11- 24؟
إيه، بالإيجاب
وأنا أقدر أقولك ترى كثير وجهات متقدمة عايشة على 5-8 بالإيجاب
بس خلني أقول لك شيء، لأن الكلام اللي طرحته صحيح
ترى التجربة عندنا
البنية التحتية، أنا ما أدّعي أن البنية التحتية ممتازة
ونتكلم عن الطرق والزحام، ما نتكلم ...
ترى مستوى السواقة حتى يخوّف الناس اللي يستأجرون سيارات
وعندنا تحديات كثيرة
وتروح ما تلقى مثلًا مرشدين بكل اللغات
فاحنا قاعدين نبني هذا القطاع
لكن أيش السبب الأول للانطباع الإيجابي عند الناس؟
هو السعوديين، هو الترحاب، هو الحفاوة السعودية اللي تكلمنا عنها
هو اللي يجيك واحد في الشارع ويبتسم لك
أنت جاي سائح؟ كذا لقافة
بس هذه اللقافة محببة عند السياح
ويقول لك، أيش عجبك؟ أيش اللي ما عجبك؟
هذا الإنفتاح بقلوب الناس قبل الكلام، وهذا مو مسؤول
ترى إذا واحد خدمك في المطار قلت والله محترف، بس ما بتتأثر
لكن لما يجيك واحد في الشارع ويوقفك؛ هذا اللي فعلًا بيأثرك
وأقدر أقول لك قصص كثيرة
شركات، رؤساء شركات دعيناهم يزوروا المملكة سياحية
فيه بعضهم، أذكر وحدة من رؤساء الشركات أمريكية
تعنى بالشريحة يمكن ذوات الدخل المرتفع، مقرها نيويورك
رفضت أنها تقابلني
أول طلب، وبعدين شافتني التقيت فيها بمعرض وسمعتني أتكلم
وبعدين زارت معرض لزملائي كانوا مشاركين فيه في أمريكا
المهم قررت تجي
بس قالت ما بغى أحد من الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
يشوفني ولا يعرف عن جدول زيارتي
قعدت ست أيام، جالت بدون ما نعرف أيش سوّت
بعدين كلمت الشخص الموظف اللي معني بالسوق الأمريكي
قالت له إذا أقدر أقابلك، أنا باقي لي يومين وبسافر
إذا أنت موجود، قابلها
جلست تتعشى معه، وقالت له لن أغفر لنفسي
أنا شفت من الناس ما لازم أُخبر به الناس اللي هناك
فالأمثلة كثيرة
وما دام نتكلم على موضوع الأرقام واللي تحقق، وسياح الداخل
فيه انطباع، ولا أظنه انطباع أظنه حقيقة
أن السياحة السعودية أو الوجهات السياحية السعودية هي للطبقة الثرية
ماهي للطبقة المتوسطة
الطبقة المتوسطة جدًّا منزعجة من عدم توفر خيارات لهم
فيه تجاهل واضح
أنت تلاقي العُلا فيه استهداف لشريحة معينة
السودة الآن نسمع نوعية المشاريع اللي فيها
أيضًا تستهدف شريحة معينة
مشروع البحر الأحمر واضح من مستوى التنفيذ الحالي
قاعد يستهدف مين
فالشريحة اليوم المتوسطة، ترى بأنها غير مستهدفة في السياحة الداخلية
وصار عندها خيارات أرخص وأريح بكثير في تركيا، في مصر، في دبي
وبدينا نشوف بعد ما كان فيه حماس للسياحة الداخلية
بدأ ينخفض الحماس هذا
بدينا نشوف عودة اكتظاظ الوجهات الإقليمية
اللي يمكن ما بنقدر ننافسهم بالأسعار، فأيش رأيك؟
ثلاث نقاط، النقطة الأولى
تحب رقم ثلاثة
أنا فعلًا...
ماشية معاك
فعلًا، أحب رقم ثلاثة
أول شيء فيه ارتفاع في الأسعار غير مبرر
وفيه عندك عرض وطلب
كل ما كان العرض أقل من الطلب، ترتفع الأسعار
وتشوف في الصيف الأسعار في الرياض نازلة
والأسعار في عسير مرتفعة
والقيمة ومستوى الخدمة
لا يتناسب مع الأسعار
لا يتناسب مع الأسعار، لكن هذا عرض وطلب
وكل ما زاد العرض، كل ما زادت المنافسة
وبالتالي الأسعار حتى تتوازن
نصيحتي للسياح
احجزوا بدري
إن كان طيران، تلقى الحين ثلث السعر اللي بتدفعه لو تستنى الشتاء
وتقرر تروح الرياض عشان موسم الرياض
الثلث، وأنا مسؤول عن كلامي
أنا في مجلس إدارة الخطوط السعودية وأعرف
احجزوا الغرف
في عسير، احنا رحنا في زيارة تفقدية
قعدنا في فندق الغرفة بـ 600 ريال، خمسة نجوم
نفس الفندق الآن واحنا نتكلم ونسجّل بـ 1100
يعني الضعف 80% زيادة
احجزوا بدري
فيه ارتفاع في الأسعار مبرر
احنا قاعدين نبني وجهات وتجارب نوعية
لأننا بنبحث عن السائح النوعي
ما بنبحث عن ...
احنا مثل ما قلت لك النجاح الاقتصادي
أنه يكون عندك الإنفاق في المملكة
فلا بد أنك أنت ترفع الجودة بما يستقطب ويستهوي هذه الشرائح الأبرز
الآن، هل هذا النقطة الثالثة، هل هذا معناته
أنه ما نطوّر شيء جديد لمتوسطي الدخل؟
إلا، والقادم والآتي بإذن الله
فيه شركات تعمل عليها جهات
كانت الوزارة وصندوق التنمية السياحي، وصندوق الاستثمارات العامة
فيه شركات الآن تعمل على تطوير وجهات وتجارب وفنادق
لشريحة متوسطي الدخل، بحيث أنها تعطي فرصة للجميع
للاستمتاع بهذه الثروات الطبيعية
إن كان بحر، وللا إن كان جبل، وللا إن كان صحراء
فأنتم مقتنعين الأسعار الحالية غير منطقية ولا تناسب الخدمة المقدمة
وتعملون على إيجاد هذه البدائل
جدًّا، وتفتيشها
وزارة السياحة
ترى كانت وزارة السياحة مشرّع بس
نظام السياحة توّه معتمد مؤخرًا
واللي يعطيها الصلاحية أنها فعلًا تلزم الجهات إلى درجة الإقفال
مو بس مخالفات إلى درجة الإقفال
إذا ما التزمت بالمعايير والمواصفات اللي رُخصت بناءً عليها
فيه كلام كثير على موضوع المشاهير، علاقتكم بالمؤثرين
يمكن القصة الأبرز موضوع سفير السياحة «ميسي»
سفير سياحتنا اللي عيّا يعيش عندنا
وفيه «كريستيانو رونالدو»، وفيه مغنيين، وفيه ممثلين جاؤوا العُلا
اشرح لنا أيش فلسفتكم في استقطاب النجوم العالميين
وهل العائد يساوي اللي قاعدين نصرفه عليهم؟
أنت ذكرت مشاهير، ويمكن تطرقت للاعب كرة ومشهور يروّج للسياحة
آخذ «ميسي» ابتداءً
أعرف الموضوع قاهر ناس كثير
بس احنا لما بدينا معاه، ما كنا ننظر له كلاعب
ننظر لك كشخص مشهور، محبوب
يتابعه على إنستقرام أكثر من 400 مليون سائح
الانطباع الذهني عند الناس، إذا قال هذا المشهور هذه بلد تستحق الزيارة
أكيد بيبدأ ينبني، والترغيب يبدأ ينبني
وتقدر تقيس بعدد الناس لما يطلّع تغريدة
كم الناس اللي تفاعلوا معاه، وكم الناس جاؤوا للموقع
فهل هذا أثر واضح يُقاس
والعائد المادي أو المردود المادي يوازي؟
أقول لك أكيد
كم؟
ماني قايل، بس فتات
ودامك ما شاء الله تجيب المعلومات، بتجيب المعلومة وبتتأكد من كلامي
فعلًا فتات ما عُرض عليه كلاعب
الحين ليش اختار يروح يلعب في «إنتر ميلان»
أنا أقدر أقول لك
مو «إنتر ميلان»
عفوًا «ميامي»
«ميامي»
أقدر أقول لك اللي قال لنا إياه الوكيل حقه
يقول لما دخلت «أبل» ودخلت «أديداس»
الرجال بيتقاعد ما بقى له شيء
هذولا الشركات عقودها بتترك له إرث لما بعد ما هو كلاعب
وأن هذا بالنسبة له أهم بكثير من مجرد أنه يلعب سنتين في أي بلدٍ كانت
بس اللعيبة ما ندخل في تعاقد معهم ولا المفاوضات
وقد يكون هذه فرصة أني أصحح بعض الاعتقاد السائد
لأن الناس تشوف والله أعلنا عن «رونالدو»
وشافوا «روح السعودية» فوق
احنا مثل ما قلت لك، احنا نستفيد ونستغل كل محتوى يطلع من أي جهة
فإذا كان هذا المحتوى حققته
أو هذا التعاقد نجاح حققته مثلًا وزارة الرياضة
أكيد بنشتغل معهم ونحاول أن المملكة العربية السعودية تستفيد منه
فيما يخص المشاهير المعروفين
اليوم بدينا ننظر للمشاهير بالتخصصات
ما ندوّر بس مين اللي عنده أكبر رقم
لأن فيه تطابق بين المتابعين لهذا المؤثر وهذا المؤثر
فنجي نشوف لكل بلد
نبغى نشوف المؤثر هذا بيروّج لأي شريحة
من أي بلد، على أي خطوط، إلى أي وجهات
فبدينا ندخل في تفصيل
وعندنا صراحة 300 مؤثر نراقبهم
ناس بيجذبون الناس اللي مهتمين بالتراث والثقافة
والناس اللي مهتمين بالفعاليات إن كانت موسيقى وللا أيًّ كان
وللا أزياء أيًّ كان
نجي بعدين المؤثرين اللي يمكن ما تعرف أنه مؤثرين
لأنك ما تشوفهم في الإعلام بس مهمين بالنسبة لنا
رجال الأعمال احنا استقطبنا أكثر من 1000 شخص يشتغلوا في قطاع السياحة
ومؤثرين على مستوى الأعمال والرأي
هذول ما يحبوا يعلنوا عن شغلهم، واحنا عارفين
بس أثرهم في صناعة القرار
صناعة القرار اللي تنعكس على سلاسل الإمداد
يمكن الأهم والأبرز
ترى أي بلد جديد، لما تروح بلد أول مرة تسمع عنه
ما بتقرر تحجز تروح «بوكنق دوت كوم» وتحجز وتروح
بتروح تسأل أحد قد راح، تروح لوكالة سفر
وتقوله تنصح أروح وللا ما أروح؟
هو وكالة السفر و السياحة إذا قالك ما أعرفهم
انسى، مستحيل تروح
أنا قد سمعت الحين عن فيتنام يقولون لي رائعة
ليش الله حادني، ما أدري
لكن لو يجيني واحد يشتغل في مستشار السفر
وللا واحد موظف يشتغل في وكالة سفر
يقول ترى كل اللي أرسلتهم لفيتنام رجعوا منبهرين
واللي أرسلتهم قعدوا في كذا وكذا وفيه خدمات
فبالتالي أنا أبغى هذا الشخص اللي ينصح السائح
اللي يخليه يتخطى هالعقبات الذهنية إنه هذا بلد جديد
ما أدري كيف مستوى الخدمة؟ ما أدري كيف الثقافة؟
هل بيتقبلوني؟ بيرحبوا فيني أم لا؟
هذول جبنا منهم أكثر من 1000 مختص وناصح
في هذا القطاع في سلاسل الإمداد
وبالنسبة لنا نعطيهم حوافز بعد ما يرجعوا
ونعطيهم منصة اسمها «خبير السعودية»
ندربهم أيش تنصح فيه؟ أيش تورّي الناس وأي صور؟
وبعدين نسوي عليهم تفتيش
نروح لمواقعهم أو نروح لمواقع مقار المكاتب كسائح خفي
ونشوف هل ينصحون بالسعودية، وللا بيقولك لا روح بلد ثاني أسهل لك
وهذه شغالين عليها أنتم ماشيين عليها؟
احنا نحاسب شركائنا على الأداء وعلى أرقام الوصول
الأداء اللي متفقين عليه هل تنصح أم لا؟ وعدد أرقام الوصول
هل بتجددون عقد «ميسي» كسفير للسياحة السعودية؟
أيش رأيك؟ هل تنصح فيه؟
العقد انتهى أو صار على وشك الانتهاء صح؟
احنا ندرس هذا الموضوع
أنا أعتقد الآن عنده جماهيرية عالية في أمريكا
فهو لو يقول للناس للسوق الأمريكي اليوم
يقول روحوا للسعودية، وهو يجي
يعني أنا مثلًا لما جلست مع «ميسي» وزوجته
قالت أنا بجي
الناس هاجموها مسكينة
إيه شكّوا  فيها
هي اللي ما تبغى
ترى هي، أنا أعتقد ما أبغى أجزم
أعتقد أنها بتجي هي وصديقاتها للسعودية للسياحة
بدون زوجها وبدون عقد وبدون ما ندفع لهم ولا ريال
معقولة؟
معقولتين
هذا عقد أنكم لا تقولون أن هذا عقد؟
كذا اتفقتوا معهم؟
عاد اللي تدخل في النوايا، عاد أيش أسوي لك؟
بس لا صدقًا والله
أنا قاعد أقول، تقول أنا منبهرة
«ميسي» أتوقع أنه بيطلع يتكلم
لا بد أنه يطلع يتكلم عن السعودية
لأنه هو حقيقةً مقتنع أن السعودية تستحق الزيارة
وأن الانطباع السائد غير صحيح البتة
وعلى فكرة ترى ما أعتقد واحد مثل «ميسي»
تفرق معه الفتات اللي أنا ذكرت لو ما هو مقتنع
هو جاء وزار، كان زيارتين قبل ما يوقع العقد
وقال لنا أيش تبغوني أقول؟
لأني ماني قايل شيء أنا ماني مقتنع فيه
فبتجدون العقد واضح
أنا كذا بسألك
يعني أنا ما أدري
بندرس الموضوع
تدرس الموضوع هاه؟
بس اليوم عندك «رونالدو»
«رونالدو» قدر يتكلم عن المملكة
«رونالدو» توّه مسوي إعلان في دبي
مو «رونالدو» قصدك «بنزيما»
اللي قالوا لك، اللي حضروا قالوا «بنزيما»
لأن عقده قديم قبل ما يوقّع، فلازم يوفي
حتى ما راح، لو شفت الإعلان تراها بصور مفبركة
يعني تنظيف الشاشة أو شيء مثل كذا
صحيح
عقود اللعيبة الجدد اللي قاعدين ينضمون الآن
الآن نتعاون مع وزارة الرياضة بحيث أننا نستفيد
كل مرحلة عندك قوى وميز نسبية لازم تستفيد منها
واحنا نستفيد من كل محتوى نروّج له
واللي كنا مرتكزين عليه، قد لا نرتكز عليه
لأننا نرتكز عليه ما هو أقوى وأجمل
لو أنا رائد أعمال وقاعد أسمع الحلقة هذه، وأسمع عن مرحلة
تاريخية مقبلة عليها السعودية في فتح السياحة
أنتوا الظاهر مقسمينها قسمين
إلى 2022 تسمونها «اكتشف السعودية»
من 2023-2030 أنتم مسمينها «استمتع بالسعودية»
فهي المرحلة الأهم اللي فيها المنتجات العملاقة
طبعًا مع الجائحة
دفيتوها شوي
إلى عام 2025
أنا كرائد أعمال، وين الفرص؟ وين تنصحني؟
أنا أقول لك رسالتي لكل رواد الأعمال
إذا عندك شك أن الخدمة اللي ممكن تقدمها في مجال السياحة
يكون لها طلب وللا لا؟ أقول لك إيه
والوجهة اللي تروح لها صندوق التنمية السياحي
بدأ الصندوق بالمشاريع الكبيرة والنوعية
واللي هي نسميها «متغيّرات اللعبة»
اليوم بدينا نشوف أن الفرص النوعية قد تأتي من الشركات الصغيرة
وسووا صندوق خاص بالشركات الصغيرة المتوسطة ورواد الأعمال
وعندنا أمثلة كثيرة احنا في الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
حاولنا نوصل لرواد الأعمال
وطلّعنا برنامج مع قناة الـ«إم بي سي» سميناه «كرام»
طلع من البرنامج التلفزيوني طلبات كثير جاتنا بالألاف
منها منصة «حيّهم»
هذه منصة «حيّهم» أو بالإنقليزي «هاي هوم»
كلها تجارب سعودية أصيلة، وعليها نمو كل سنة
دعمنا مثلًا أحد القصص الناجحة الرائعة، السكن التشاركي
وكل صيف نرفع معدل السكن بالتعاون معهم
ومعدلات الطلب عليها كبيرة
إن كان في التقنية، والخدمات، الصرف، الترجمة
التسويق، منصات إذا كنت بتسوي برامج للمبيعات
كل الخدمات اللي تخدم القطاع السياحي
إذا عندك شك، أبغى أقول لك اقطع الشك باليقين
وروح للصندوق وغالبًا بيدرسوا معاك دراسة الجدوى ويتم تمويلك
يقولون قانون عشرين ثمانين
صحيح
مين هي الـ 20% من الدول اللي بتجيب لنا 80% من السياح؟
مركزين على مين انتم؟
طبعًا كل غرض العشرين ثمانين تختلف
بس أنا أتكلم أنت بتسألني عن مثلًا العمرة
بتظل الدول الإسلامية هي اللي بتقدم لك أكبر الأعداد
مهما زاد العدد من مثلًا بلد مثل أيًّ كان
نقول في أوربا، بلجيكا
حتى لو كانوا أثرياء، لن يغطوا الملايين اللي يجوك من إندونيسيا
الكلام على السياحة أقدر أقول لك
أنه أنت تنظر لأيش اللي عندك معروض؟
أنا لو عندي مثلًا سياحة التسوّق هي الرائدة
أبغى أقول لك أنه الشرائح اللي بتجي
بتكون من مثلًا الصين
هم أكبر المتسوقين في العالم اللي يروحون يصرفون في التسوق
احنا لو تشوف الوجهات اللي الحين قاعدين نطورها
إن كانت ثقافة أو إن كانت وجهات بحرية
أتوقع السياحة البحرية والشواطئ بتكون هي الجاذب الأكبر
ومين اللي بيجيك وبيصرف؟ مين الـ 20% و 80%؟
بقدر أقولك اللي عندهم يخوت، اللي عندهم قوارب
اللي يشتروا بيوت ثانوية
إن كانت هذه البيوت الثانوية في مكة والمدينة
وللا إن كانت البيوت الثانوية في عسير، في مصيف
وللا إن كانت بيوت عائمة
اللي يثبتوا اليخوت عندنا على الوجهات البحرية
فما أقدر أقول لك والله هي دولة
هي شرائح في كل هذه الدول
بس ليش أحس أنكم مركزين فقط على الغرب؟
هل لأنهم شقر وكشخة أنه تجيب سياح أجانب؟ طيب الصينيين؟
والله أنت اللي ...
وللا هذا انطباعي أنا؟
هذا انطباعك
طيب الصينيين، أحس أنكم ساحبين على الصينيين
هذا الإحساس من وين جاي طالع عمرك؟
ما أشوفهم
أولًا هم سامحين لهم يسافرون، هذا واحد
الثاني، بالعكس احنا اليوم أعلنا مع هيئة الطيران المدني ما قصروا
بدينا في مطار الرياض، فيه كل اللوائح الإرشادية
أصبحت مترجمة بالصيني
لأن قاعدين نركز على السائح الصيني
كنت أنا مشارك مع وزير السياحة في المؤتمر الصيني السعودي
وتكلمنا عن الجهوزية للسائح الصيني
وتكلمنا أنه عندنا إن شاء الله إعلان قريب
مع رئيس مجلس إدارة شركة «أكور» عندهم أربعين فندق
حتكون كلها جاهزة للصينيين في القريب العاجل
عندنا ثلاث خطوط بنبدأ نشغلها من الصين
قريبًا بنعلن إن شاء الله في الصين
والحملة الإعلامية اللي بتواكب الإطلاق
أو الإعلان الرسمي للمملكة العربية السعودية
كوجهة تنصح بها الحكومة الصينية
بتصاحبها حملة إعلامية ضخمة
أشوف لمعالي الوزير جولة...
عفوًا ترى حتى في الهند فتحنا مكاتب مع وزارة الخارجية
والشركة المشغلة للتأشير
فتحنا مكاتب كثير لتسهيل الحصول على التأشيرات
إن شاء الله الآن بننتقل إلى المنصات الإلكترونية
أوزباكستان، كازاخستان
صار عندنا خطوط مباشرة مخطط لها من خلال ربط
لا ، قاعدين نركز على كل...
رحت لإندونيسيا، رحت لكل هذه الدول اللي أنا ذكرت لك إياها
وأشوف أنا جولة لمعاي وزير السياحة في الخليج
وتوقيع اتفاقية التأشيرات السياحية الموحدة
أظن أن بالنسبة للناس مثلًا في أمريكا اللاتينية، وللا أمريكا وللا الصين
مثلنا نحن لما نروح إلى أوربا، أو نروح إلى اليابان وللا كوريا
ماني بضارب مشوار على دولة واحدة وللا مكان واحد
غالبًا أبغى آخذ لي تمشية في البقعة هذه
فلو تسولف لنا على موضوع التأشيرة الموحدة
وأيش فكرتها ووين قاعدين نوصل فيها؟
هذا مسار تعمل عليه وزارة السياحة
لكن الوزير كان يجمعنا ويقول استفدنا من تجربة قطر في كأس العالم
«هيّا» إيه الناس جات لقطر والدوحة
وبعدين جاءت السعودية وراحت بسبب التسهيل هذا
ليش ما نبدأ؟ مو لازم مع كل الدول
نبدأ مع دولة بعد الأخرى
يمكن اللي أعلن عنه اللي ذكرته، كانت وزيرة السياحة البحرينية
بعد ما التقت بوزير السياحة السعودي
وكذلك عُمان بعد وللا لا؟
أنا اللي أعلم عنه عن هذا، لأنني كنت في الاجتماع
وأننا نبحث كيف نكرر هذه التجربة، ونبدأ نعممها
بس ما بعد أُعلن عن أي شيء إلى الآن
سؤال قبل الأخير
تفضل
في رحلة السائح أو الزائر اللي من برّا
وين كانت أكثر نقطة منخفضة في الرضا
خلنا نورطك مع الجهات
متى؟ لأن هذا متغير
آخر رصد أيش كانت النقطة الأدنى في رضا السائح؟
الزحام
حتى هذا وصل لهم هم اللي مجننا!
لأن السائح ترى ما يبغى يجي ويقضي ثلاثة أربع
أو نقول مثلًا ساعة ساعتين قاعد ينتقل من مكان لمكان
المفروض ينتقل له في خلال ربع ساعة أو ثلث ساعة
فالرياض اليوم أصبحت من أهم الوجهات السياحية
اللي ما فيها من فعاليات وأعمال
وحتى الدرعية، المصمك، المتاحف، كل شيء
حافة العالم
فالرياض، أنا وأنت عايشين فيها ونعرف مشاكل الزحام
عسير في الصيف كانت أهم مشكلة الزحام
يعني لا يتفرد الزحام
أنت سألتني عن الأعلى
أنت أول رئيس للهيئة السعودية للسياحة
كل قادة هذا القطاع هم مؤسسين لمرحلة
تاريخية في السعودية لقطاع جديد
قاعد يبدأ ويطلق قدراته
يومًا ما بتغادر مثل أي مسؤول
سامع شيء؟
سم؟
يمكن، ترى يقولون دائمًا اللي يقابلهم سقراط يُعفون بعدها
فالله يستر عليك
الله يسلمك شكرًا
أو يترقّون ما ندري
لكن الفكرة هي بتغادر يومًا ما
أيش أكثر شيء بتكون فخور فيه سواءً تحقق
أو تتمنى تحققه لما تغادر هذا الكرسي؟
اللي أتمناه، وأعمل جاهدًا من أجله
أني أبني قيادات لهذا الوطن أينما حلوا
ومحترفين في صناعة السياحة
والاحترافية تأتي بعمل مؤسسي
بقياس أداء والتزام بأهداف ومحاسبة المسؤولين
إما بإنجازات ونشكرهم ونثني على ما قاموا به
وإذا كان جهد ولم يحقق المأمول
نستفيد من كل الدروس المستفادة
اليوم أنا فخور فعلًا بالفريق اللي حولي
واستطاع أنه يخليني أتحدث نيابةً عنهم
صدق والله، ترى ماهي مجاملة
عندي فريق رائع، احنا اليوم قربنا 600 موظف
عندنا ناس تتكلم 26 لغة
عالميين فكرًا، احترافيًا
ولازلنا جدد على القطاع
فبالتالي، وبيكون فيه طلب عليهم كبير
أنا إذا أُعفيت، أتمنى أنه هم يستقطبوا لقيادات في هذا القطاع
موفقين إن شاء الله
شكرًا جزيلًا لك
ونتطلع للـ 10% ناتج محلي
للأكثر من 100 مليون زائر
بنشوف أيش الهدف الجديد حقكم
وللـ 3 مليون وظيفة تُخلق إن شاء الله تعالى بحلول 2030
شكرًا جزيلًا لك
شكرًا لك أبو سارة
الله يحفظك
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لفهد القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
ياسر آل غانم في إدارة التصوير
وفي التصوير عبدالرحمن عبود
مسؤول الإضاءة غالب جانودي
ياسر كدشة مساعد إضاءة
وفي تسجيل الصوت والهندسة الصوتية عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج غيداء التميمي وأصيل بافرط
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع